for several weeks in april and may this
year it felt as though the small
neighborhood of sheikh jarrah in
occupied east jerusalem was the
epicenter of the israeli-palestinian
conflict the threat of the forced
displacement of four palestinian
families had become a focal point one of
the triggers for the round of hamas
rocket fire that marked the start of
this year's brief but bloody gaza war
six months on shakhtar is quieter but
the fate of its palestinian residents
awarded their homes by the jordanian
government in the 1950s is reaching an
acute potentially defining moment
right now we still don't know where we
are going
israel's supreme court has given the
families until the 2nd of november to
decide whether to accept a compromise
deal with a jewish settler organization
that claims ownership of the land the
deal would give them protected tenancy
status meaning they would have the right
to stay for up to three generations from
now and crucially without giving up
their own fight to be recognized as
owners of the land
we have to study this proposal very
thoroughly because it will determine our
fate our existence in the neighborhood
and we can't give any answers before we
have discussed and studied it and this
will be done by all the residents of the
neighborhood the family's campaign lent
on the success of social media moments
like this muna el kurd confronting a
settler who admitted frankly to wanting
to steal her land muna's brother
muhammad recently tweeted that the
families were deliberating but would
never accept that settlers owned their
homes legal experts say that within the
confines of the israeli law if the
supreme court had to make a final ruling
that ruling would almost certainly be
against the palestinian families on this
street they say that's one reason why
it's pushing this compromise deal so
hard so it doesn't have to make that
decision lawyer and activist daniel
siderman says even if the families do
accept the deal nothing is entirely
guaranteed you have rights but those
rights are not inalienable rights
they're alienable rights and they can be
taken from you
and the palestinians even if
the best case scenario goes through and
there is an acceptable settlement
will live a life of perpetual
vulnerability
but there is of course another factor
whether the settler organization will
accept a deal that isn't as definitive
as previous court judgments in their
favor it may prefer to force the judges
into delivering a verdict one that could
all too easily spark another round of
violence harry fawcett al-jazeera
occupied east jerusalem